welcome back to CBS morning's our next
guest Stephen Colbert needs no
introduction not not just the host of
The Late Show now he's hosting a
pickleball tournament right here on CBS
his new special is called what else
pickled celebrities are going to compete
on teams to raise money for coming safe
efforts to fight homelessness now the
winners received the coveted cold bear
cup that's right players include
celebrities like singers Kelly Rowland
and Dierks Bentley and actors Emma
Watson and Marie Bartlett we've got a
preview of how the teams prepared for
the tournament yeah
[Music]
strategy for today is to win baby we're
going to win when I knew I was going to
be playing with Ray I started training
it's like
put this man down we did Mount Everest a
few times what else did we do
Kilimanjaro we went to Africa it was
great what's your biggest
um athletic achievement today I would
say the 1976 Olympic gold medal my
biggest athletic achievement to this
date was feeding my younger brother at
ping pong ping pong
against my younger brother
[Music]
pickleball it is Stephen Colbert joins
us this morning look who's up early
[Laughter]
all-nighter baby pulled over here they
brought me over on a dolly so uh how
different is this from hosting late
night I gotta say Nate I I got to give
it up for sports broadcasting I had no
idea that you guys are way more talented
than any of us in late night do you have
to be able to do I mean Sports people do
this live right they call the game and
they shoot the game we had months to get
this together it barely made it in time
it's it's uh I'm super excited you were
surprised about the work it took today
well I had no idea how complex it was to
to shoot a a sports tournament yeah this
is the first pickleball tournament ever
broadcast on uh you know broadcast TV
wow it's the premiere one I like to say
because it's never been done before and
I was blown away by the complexity of
covering sports right right adding the
color to an already colorful sport right
which is intense in itself how did you
get into pickleball we're just assuming
you like pickleball I do like pickleball
how I got into pickleball your wife
right Evie gave me a pickleball set last
Christmas and I said what is pickleball
when I open it up this is lovely thank
you dear what is pickleball are you mad
at me yeah exactly you'll find out
because there's no way you're not every
everybody we know plays it's on fire
playing and so and then two weeks later
Funny or Die came to me and said hey
would you want to do a celebrity charity
pickleball tournament and I said two
weeks later just two weeks later it was
mid-January yeah I said I know what
pickleball is I play Pickleball and so
now when we vacation we actually look
for a place that has pickleball like a
hotel that has pickleball courts and
they're everywhere you know Stephen
what's so cool about it is I played it
for the first time just two weeks ago
I've been hearing about it too my
partner was an 11 year old boy so you
can imagine he's a I get her anyway what
I like about pickleball is that's what I
like about it it's not intimidating
because you no going in that the best
pickleball player in the world is only
about twice as good as the worst
football player basically how good are
you on a scale of one to two yes I'm a
solid one I'm a high one no but it's
true but it's good for all ages and I
have to say I did not embarrass myself I
got so thrilled when he said Nice Shot I
got I go really really really well I
mean everything's fine by it
everything's I'm a mean pickleball
player why because I keep score
I play by the rules there's so many big
names who played I remember when Drew
Brees yeah got into it and I thought
Drew Brees got in a pickleball rough for
him it's huge Sugar Ray Leonard goes to
tournaments his partner in in pickled
tonight is Emma Watson you know Hermione
Granger from Harry Potter yeah you're
good people are going to be shocked by
the ferocity that she brings to this
game really yeah and the pairings that
you do too but I think you buried the
lead here because guys on the show
Stephen Colbert is singing the National
Anthem I thought that was it you do yes
well you know vertical stripes are
slenderizing Gail
and there's nothing nothing that matches
my sallow Irish skin better than
iridescent greens very forgiving I
actually wore this color green because
it reminds me of pickle and I knew you
were coming I actually did I'm not
kidding when I was looking but the other
good thing about this is that you're
doing it all for charity you said the
lines are very funny there's somebody at
one point you said there's going to be
dashes smashes rashes because there's a
whole lot of chafing here's somebody
playing with enthusiasm who's really bad
your commentary is also funny well I
hope so I'm doing my best sometimes my
best is ridiculous no no no but it's all
for charity it's all for comic relief
you all remember like uh Whoopi and
Billy and Ross back in the 90s but
people know about red nose day but they
don't know the comic relief has never
gone away they've raised hundreds of
millions of dollars for children and
families in need lead and you know to
give them stability and a chance to get
back on their feet and hopefully we'll
raise a lot of money for it tonight just
hit that QR code hit that QR code QR
code that's what we're using these days
uh by the way a little bit of news I
don't know if you follow the news but uh
yeah Donald Trump announced that he's
going to run for president speaking of
being in the picture yeah speaking of
being in a picture I'm not I'm not aware
not aware I'm aware I'll have to look
into that I get all my news from late
night so I don't really actually know
what's going on how do you prepare for
news like that how do you prepare I
don't prepare for news at all I just
react to whatever's going on we're just
a shadow of what you real news people do
we see what you talk about and we go I
have an opinion on that too uh-huh but I
think when you heard he was running and
he's been forecasted again for long this
time when you're talking about what is
yours no no Steve did you Stephen did
you see the cover of the post yesterday
it said Florida man makes announcement
So when you say who is this man you're
speaking about but when you heard it did
you think okay it's going to give me
another two years of material or did you
think okay been there done that what did
you think uh when I heard it I thought I
could I get a prescription of Xanax that
lasted two years I have uh I have uh
almost uh zero interest in doing jokes
about someone who I think that is that
detrimental to our democracy who at the
beginning of his campaign starts off as
a tragedy not as a clown um some other
news James Corden announced that uh
he'll be leaving the Late Late Show what
Frank can surprise surprise it's a good
thing you came here you were in that
space who would you like to see take
over that spot why not you oh you'd be
fantastic I got enough jobs right you
got to keep this job too yeah that's
right that's right I I I haven't it's
not me that's all I know I can only do
one hour a night one hour a night
Trevor no is available
[Laughter]
some celebrity names for these teams are
uh the volley ranchers yes
um when Harry Harry Met Harry Harry
Harry
and party till you cue oh party too he's
cute what would your team be
well I was one team name that I really
like that I wish I could if I played I
would want that name which is a dill I
am oh
Dylan who's the better pickleballer Mr
or Mrs Colbert oh Mrs see I can't answer
that I can't accurately and safely come
on you are a man who speaks the truth no
I'm not I'm a man who tells jokes
Mrs Colbert is way better than I am
because she has liquid Grace yeah like
family doesn't always win but she looks
better losing oh okay they're like
Family Feud good answer good answer
show me Evie
Stephen can you just say something about
the Colbert trophy what is it Colbert
The Colbert cup uh I don't want to
reveal too much but if anyone out there
confused it with a high school karate
trophy I wouldn't think you were crazy
right so and the idea that we left it to
the last minute and could not find a
pickle based trophy in time I find
insulting Gail yeah which is I believe
insinuation of your question well I know
this is going to be fun there's a mascot
too you forgot to say there's a mascot
half sour Harvey yeah it's a popular
sport weekly depressed mascot he's going
to be fine yeah and we're going to have
fun watching it we appreciate it and
it's for great cause as well Stephen
Colbert thank you so much pickled airs
tonight right here on CBS in streams
live and On Demand on Paramount plus
don't miss it stick around for it I'm
telling you you're going to love it